pilar mazzetti renunció tras el
escándalo que relaciona el expresidente
martín vizcarra con las vacunas de
scinopharm un medio local denunció que
el expresidente habría recibido la dosis
de la vacuna en octubre del año pasado y
no solamente él sino también su esposa
esto enojó a muchos congresistas quienes
ya estaban preparando una moción de
destitución masetti se sintió acorralada
y presentó su carta de dimisión al
presidente francisco sagasti esto
preocupa porque la renuncia de masetti
se produce cuando perú ya ha iniciado la
primera fase de su vacunación una
vacunación que está siendo criticada por
muchos médicos y enfermeras quienes
acusan que han sido excluidos de las
nóminas que habían sido programadas por
el ministerio de salud oscar ugarte va a
ser el nuevo encargado de la cartera
fuentes de palacio me han señalado que
el bajo juramentar hoy al mediodía y él
precisamente será el encargado de
recibir las 700.000 dosis de zinc o farc
que van a llegar esta noche al país
oscar ugarte es un médico de profesión
él ya tiene experiencia en
pues ha sido ministro de salud en el
segundo gobierno del ex presidente alan
garcía entre los años 2008 y 2011 y
también tiene conocimiento de lo que
está haciendo el estado peruano con
respecto a la atención de la pandemia
del cob y 19 porque él ha sido miembro
del denominado comando vacuna y ha
estado presente en las reuniones vamos a
ver cómo le va a este nuevo ministro en
perú